why are we pretending that Ludacris is a
badass you know there's nothing more
2000s than ludicrous if you google 2003
Ludacris comes up Cadillac grills
Cadillac Spears or watch out my Cadillac
grills Cadillac Mills Cadillac Hills or
watch on my Cadillac drills Ludacris
they're like can you do this movie and
he was like oh it's about cars hell yeah
can I Drive a cadillac grills Cadillac
Brill's Cadillac Friel in the agents I
come Ludacris calm down calm down
excuse me calm down okay I'm just
excited well I hope it's a Cadillac
frailes and the agents like I came what
do you want to do with her wives like
sure rails and then he got on set and
they were like hey so here's the car
he's like what the [ __ ] that's not a
Cadillac brailles Cadillac thrills then
you have the [ __ ] thing called
chicken and beer the the
lazy 20 inch wide 20 inches high oh
don't you like about 28 ride 20 inch
ride it's a con the candy quote-unquote
paint job high gloss finish on his
Cadillac is impressive hence he ends up
filling lots of women with his Cadillac
in their name parentheses nickname for
his penis dude I can't believe that is a
song it bangs though doesn't it
[Music]